[Music]
there's a restaurant in la that i know
we've talked about on the show before
called the griddle uh it's a great
breakfast spot if you're ever in the
neighborhood on sunset in fairfax and
the manager there is a guy named alex
who over the years has become somebody
we see often and the last time i think
chris and i were both in there
alex who's a very positive um
person he said hey you know good to see
you guys and uh and he looked at
christian and he said
wow you have lost a lot of weight gee
and he couldn't believe it he just
couldn't and even throughout the meal
he'd come over to me and like i can't
believe how much weight your brothers
lost and
even subsequently texting me it was
there was always a reference made to how
much weight you lost for the record i've
never lost or gained
more than uh
eight pounds probably since i was 19
years old yeah so he definitely got the
wrong person
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
and i'm here with my brother felt
regular
sized brother
thank you yeah there occasion where i
see you you know heavier than not a few
pounds here or there he definitely got
the wrong person i was like both
flattered that he was paying me such a
positive compliment yeah but also
insulted that he clearly had the wrong
person right because ordinarily that
would be a really he yeah he meant it oh
that was a huge compliment he was like
it's amazing what you've accomplished
you've losing all this weight that's a
very rare thing i would think a positive
insult
you know like god you are so
nice you're just so nice you're you're
not nearly the way you used to be it's
not really a compliment because no he
wasn't wrong directed towards me that's
true in fact i think it's probably just
insulting because he didn't remember
yeah you used to go in there all the
time
not all the time that's right i just
didn't i mean i'm willing to concede
that i never made much of an impact on
that guy well that's what i never
understand about people who get insulted
by you don't remember me you know
yeah i'm not insulted he doesn't
remember i was a little insulted that he
went on and on about it
after i said well that's it definitely
wasn't that's just weird me that's just
weird yeah well speaking of mass weight
loss yeah our guest today played a
character on tv
for seven years
who uh lost a lot of weight and the
character is uh schmidt a new girl and
the actor our guest today is max
greenfield max is uh one of the funniest
one of my favorite people and
uh uh has been a friend ever since i did
a few episodes of the show new girl
which i did before it was on the air so
my introduction to max's comedic genius
was just to see it in person um
and if you know the show you know that
max
max plays a version of a guy who who was
formerly overweight like very overweight
max plays schmidt on new girl and
schmidt the character was an overweight
kid in high school in college and
there's
several flashbacks to this over the
course of the series uh christian and i
weirdly enough know
the actual person
on whom schmidt the character was based
jonah hill is a friend of ours and jonah
went to school with a guy named schmidt
who
uh was
not
much like the character schmidt
he was never
overweight and lost weight did he no nor
was he nor did he have the kind of like
more flamboyant how would you describe
schmidt that they kind of like um like
nothing like the characters no no so i
think maybe it's just the namesake yeah
i think so liz merriweather who created
the show was friends with those guys as
well and i think liz just named i think
it was as simple as that although
schmidt whenever jonah would talk about
his friend schmidt uh i had heard about
so many stories about him before i met
him and he was always like integral to
these funny stories so maybe that's
where liz got it from she was always
hearing oh and then schmidt did this
other thing and like classic schmidt it
was he was talked about in that uh
in that vein you know as yeah like a
character in that group so you worked on
new girl like you said and but you
didn't have a very good time on that
show did you you didn't have much fun
well you're gonna have to wait and find
out for the interview
it was one yeah it was
one of the most fun jobs i i hesitate to
say that only because i feel like i say
that often now on the show and i realize
that how lucky i am to be able to do
this job like i've had so many fun jobs
just just to be very
trite sounding i've had a lot of fun
jobs but this was definitely
one of the more fun jobs and uh but
anyway yeah and the script was great but
um
it was meeting max and jake and lamorne
morris jake johnson and uh and
working with those guys that made it the
most fun i mean the best the best job
anyway uh we'll talk about that well if
you haven't seen new girl
max is also in veronica mars and he's
in the cbs show the neighborhood which
is uh
season two is premiering mm-hmm this
fall at some point yeah i think the end
of september early october and uh he's
just an overall
hilarious um really funny great such a
great guy yeah and um
so hopefully uh you guys will agree i
think you will uh
a couple of minutes into this my
chat with my pal max greenfield life
could be a dream
you're in line at a coffee shop there's
a guy that you don't want to see sure he
goes uh oh my god max it's so good to
see you i i wish i could catch up so
much to catch up but i'm running i
actually am late for a thing so he
starts going doubles back and he says
you know what [ __ ] it i have half hour
let's talk hey man i'm so sorry i really
gotta run but we should catch up
you're running now
yeah where are you going but see i have
a different excuse now the kids oh right
i got a bunch of stuff with the kids
perfect yeah oh you're not tied to
anything man no no no dude i gotta go no
you're my dating app yeah you
you have all the time in the world
that's why nobody asked me for a half
hour i'm actually really flattered that
you didn't use your kids is it because
you could have today
uh
rather than doing this so i'm like
flattered well if i'm being totally
honest with you
when you texted me you forgot
i had
not even the slightest clue that i was
supposed to be here today
i couldn't believe it went back into the
email and was like
there you go
justin's right
wow i didn't hear that very often i had
a bit i had a big mind a big morning
yeah what'd you do yeah man my daughter
uh lizzy lily it's fine sorry it's fine
i just wanted to see if you knew
well it's ozzy right and lily yeah yeah
you you combine it yeah that's good
that's funny
but she uh
had a presentation they did they do
these biography presentations she's in
third grade and she had to do one on
frida kahlo
and
we've been working on it yeah man we've
been working on it for like
the better part of three weeks
people have asked me what like if i'm
working on for the hiatus and i'm like
yeah i'm sort of i have this intense
biography report
um there was like a poster board
and
a full report that had to be with like
you first start with 12 questions you
asked the 12 questions and then after
you have your answers for the 12
questions you form it into like a speech
and then they have to dress up like
frida kahlo she has to dress up like
free or whoever you have and then today
was the presentation day oh my god it
was a big lead up to this and it was a
did you do it yeah man it was a lot of
stress
see now my first thought is
uh what did you do for the her the
eyebrow did you fill in her yes you did
yeah i'm looking at a picture
lily really cute but so her eyebrows
naturally like that too which is totally
yeah we didn't have to do anything which
was good that's why she picked up
in the first place
yeah
they actually they call her they hey
unibrow um
for you so i
i mean i truly because there's
there's only so much a third grader can
do yeah and then
so i mean so you you
you end up putting a lot of work into it
and uh i did
and we went in there and let me tell you
something she was
truly
phenomenal yeah just i mean is she
imitating frida kahlo is she no she just
she she gives a rep she might be
offensive
maybe
maybe especially for like the white kid
who's like jackie robinson like chill
out man
connor you'll be frederick douglass yeah
that's right there's a lot of those
but so she
they think he's like uh doc brown from
back to the future no the the real the
yeah
no they're other girls
so
so i i'm like all morning i'm stressed
out like i'm like being like really
short with tests tests like will you
chill out it's not your report i'm like
yeah it kinda is
it's become mine
we go through the whole thing there's
questions that the kids are great
they're asking these great questions
comments afterwards whole thing huge
success honestly got emotional
and i was like oh you're watching off to
the side you're not with her we're no
we're we're we're in the back of the
room
and then tess my wife you know
texts me after
and goes
hey you spelled kylo wrong on the poster
i said no i didn't
i'm reading a text exchange right now
you spelled the kalo wrong no what are
those
[ __ ] you because i got it right
she sends me this a picture of her by
the board and i put the h in the wrong
place
[Laughter]
and then she sends me more proof to show
that that it's wrong on the board and
then it's right in real life
so i write oh no oh no oh no i'm
dyslexic
are you i might be i don't know okay
this may be if i'm if i am i'm
discovering it now if you are it's mean
of her to text you i don't think anyone
noticed but the teachers and the ladies
[Laughter]
can i see
i don't think anyone it's huge
so i'm looking at it but the kids don't
know except for the adults lily looks so
much like frida kahlo hopefully or i'm
sorry calho frida calhoun that hopefully
it
distracted people that's been sitting on
a board by the way in our kitchen
i made that board like
a week and a half ago it's been sitting
up there
deeply wrong we've read the book eight
times listen tess had ample opportunity
to see it that's what i'm saying how did
you meet tess
oh god sorry
uh but i'm curious how did you
we were just out
like hide
it sort of yeah oh
really
yeah sort of
what was it it was like
nationale oh you remember that place on
wilcox yes we always like we'll drive
through the quingo corridor and be like
this is where it all started
so nationale was like oh funny enough
sarah pantera second time on a podcast
not mentioning her uh
we were i was just she just texted me i
was just thinking about her and like i
see these old
monuments to like my old days of like
going out and not that i was like a big
club guy but there were no but we were
around the same age like young in your
20s like that was a bit i mean
maybe it's a big thing now i don't know
but like i don't know
that area was yeah there was like a
different club every night and you were
like
let's go and try to get in yeah yeah
who's you were way more famous than i
was back then i was like not working at
all you were like walking right in the
front door i was deep i was deep in line
i was walking with like togo and yeah
you were like in there and i was like
there's justin long [ __ ] man
oh there's my future wife oh but justin
got it i ran like one of those ryan
gosling with like dj that's how cool it
was yeah totally um i'd hear about it
you couldn't get in but like i'd heard
about all that [ __ ] but you got in one
night and that's and then i was like i'm
pulling something out of this
i'm pulling the rest of my life out of
this yeah uh so you guys were all
[ __ ] around i was like i'm getting
white yeah i don't want to have to do
this again i don't know
i'll never get in again
i want to do [ __ ] book reports
there's a free color book report in me
and uh
and if i could just spell her name right
that's really funny
so it was just like a regular you
met her and saw her and
yeah well we started dating and i mean
not to be like
but it's been one of those things we're
like oh man it's gotten better and
better yeah yeah yeah yeah so this was
like 15 this is also a long time ago
how long yeah because you've been
celebrated 15 years we've been married
for 10 but together 15. jesus yeah good
for you i mean good maybe
oh look you're doing the room
you got two kids
you're doing justin long's part
look how far you've gotten
now you're my guest um
you i saw an episode of you were on
ellen degeneres talking about lily i
think lily's the one that loves helen
did some research for this it's so funny
it's so good because you come out
everyone should watch this you come out
and you do this ridiculous dance
which it turns out you were imitating
beth bear's beth bears is your co-star
in on the neighborhood yeah
yeah sorry i'm from um thank you
it's actually you know beth is you and
beth are on the neighborhood honestly
i've been searching for her name yeah
bears for the first for the whole season
oh oh i'm so it's like one of those
you're like oh my god i'm so happy
you're doing this but it's like you
never asked the name and then it's just
you go the whole time like at some point
it'll come up yeah you've already asked
no
but you come out you and you're like
twerking and doing this
and ellen says
at first i didn't know what you were
doing
and then i realized that you were
imitating beth bears doing her dance
yeah yeah
what
and i've had that experience walking
onto those shows it is like
i just want to get to the couch you just
want to like well interesting how the
[ __ ] did you do that how did you commit
to that and i think it speaks volumes
about you as a performer thank you so
much i appreciate it and thank you for
not like for let's for starting with
like the really good that's something
i'm most proud of
um
some people know you from no totally
please i think this is great you know
obviously getting into why i think it's
important okay okay okay um
i wanted to do something where first you
know you're gonna have to dance on that
night ellen yeah when you do ellen
you're like i'm gonna have to dance
right and you're like i'm not the guy
that's going to walk and be like no i'm
not dancing that's and it's like come on
yeah of course yeah um you certain
people can do that yeah yeah
it's like come on yeah yeah cornell west
can do that sure why not
so
i was so i was like i was trying to you
always try to like tie it in some way to
the show and we were still launching a
show at that point and beth like the
last time she did the show she was like
i remember she was on her way there and
she was like i'm really not i'm gonna
try my best not to go crazy on the dance
like i think i last time i went nuts and
i really i don't even know what i'm
doing out there and i watch it back and
i'm sort of like half humiliated and
she's like i'm really gonna try to like
just ease my way over was this when she
was in a princess outfit for halloween
no no no that was amazing
so
so then
i see her the next day i go i had to go
and she goes it's like i black out
and i watched it and she went 150 miles
yeah
past where she was last time and you're
like what's wrong
but so i was like i'm going to see if i
can do it that's a i felt like i
half-assed it a little bit and i and i
i
wish i knew exactly because i didn't
really know exactly where i was going
from one thing to the next and when i
watched back hers and i'm like making a
dumb face and i was like oh my god
but the foul because what i was trying
to do that time and because you if you
want you can go there and you can
request the music oh and i tried and
when i got there i was like hey do you
guys have any huey lewis
and they go no i know what you want to
do back to the future thing no i just
like i like dancing oh
it puts me in a good mood
so
so i asked for you they didn't have it
and i go all right i'll do the best
thing so i tried to do my best dancing
with beth
but i just did it recently
and
i put on huey lewis and i honestly
thought and sedakis was hosting it of
all people uh-huh and i thought he'd be
he'd be down for this he was hosting
what ellen they have a guest host every
once in a while
and uh and i thought this was good so i
asked ahead of time and they got the
rights for for uh harder rock and roll
and i could have danced for all for the
whole stuff for four minutes
it was [ __ ] great dude let me tell
you something i did it and i danced for
a while it was probably a full minute
was jake did today is trying he was like
he was into it oh he was like fake
playing the sacks
we were in a good zone we were connected
and uh
i've never gotten more people have
written me about that one dance sequence
from ellen dancing to huey lewis
any of the work that i've ever done
well here's why i think it's important
okay and here's why i
here's what i took note of is that you
because i was putting myself in your
shoes and i was like oh my god i i i
couldn't do that i couldn't come out
commit it's a it's a level of commitment
that i think few actors have and this is
going to be weird because we're friends
and like for me to compliment you
but you also by the way if if put in the
right scenario would commit
a thousand i would aspire to that level
of i've i yes i try i've seen you
but i
you on new girl was the first time i was
introduced to you
some of those scenes i mean you say
things like the one line you say i uh
you go this is nectar you're talking
about how cool something is and you're
what this is nectar i'll never forget
jake johnson comes up to me and this is
like season five when i was like
my body hurt from all the physicality
i'm like we were shooting this show
which was like 16 hour dates especially
in the beginning and i was like oh my
god they'd written like yet another
insane thing for me to do where i'm like
hanging off some [ __ ] or jumping into a
wall whatever the [ __ ] i'm doing yeah
jake comes in he goes justin was here in
the first season and he he pointed over
to you and you were doing some dumb
about me and he goes he's gonna regret
this come season five six
when they're still asking him to do this
[ __ ] well cause you're so good at it you
were doing a lot of parkour stuff in the
first season the thing i love and this
honestly ties back to beth which i love
so much about working with beth
is she is like me where
it's like you know let's like not ask a
bunch of questions let's just jump in
yeah go 150 miles an hour yeah fail
miserably
but see where we're at see what stuff
does land because some of that yeah
totally yeah and that's why i love
working with her and like we'll do these
husband and wife scenes
in the neighborhood and
it just starts off in a place where oh
we know exactly what works we know
exactly what doesn't work and then we
can just work from there you're talking
about just rehearsing yeah yeah that's
what's so nice about the multi you get
to rehearse it is that hard for you
though to not
get to because you're such a good
improviser is it hard to kind of like
restrict you no i like it yeah i like it
i sort of was i i was sort of done yeah
with them we did so much improvising
they started expecting a lot of you
i didn't have any left yeah yeah i just
was like i i there's no no more areas
yeah all of my material was gone
maybe like three quarters into season
one
and then we were just doing weird
[ __ ] bits that like made no sense and
only made us laugh
and like you can't really like you can
take credit for an improv that that
comes out of like oh we're in a scene
and you're thinking about it but when
you're delirious at three in the morning
and you're like on [ __ ] mars and some
[ __ ] comes out of your mouth that you
then watch an episode of you know seven
years later and you go i don't remember
this at all this is like a different
human well i i've only had this a few
times where i i remember
that being in that state where you're
like i'm just going to make some [ __ ] up
and like just entertain each other and
because because the the writers have
kind of run out of ideas and stuff i was
on totally not as long as new girl but
long enough to know that it's like the
writers will be like just get you know
you'll figure it out you'll find well i
it's not even so much that because the
writers were really wonderful on new
girl and liz in particular but liz had a
thing where she stayed involved she
stayed oh yeah
but like i think you have a thing and i
think probably a lot of writers have
this where they're
where maybe the initial thing that you
wrote was funny
but by the time it reaches
a place where you're shooting it and
it's up on its feet and it's being said
out loud you've heard it so many times
right between the table read and having
written it and rehearsed or whatever
that you want something else you want
something new that's fresh yeah and it's
a weird thing because just because it's
fresh for you
doesn't mean that it's funnier than the
original thing that you wrote right um
yeah that i'm so doesn't that happen in
the neighborhood though i mean well so
that well i mean that i think it just
comes from like the neighborhood's
interesting with the multicam it's
totally different because it's it's it's
it's all rhythm we're sorry i
interrupted you
but that that would happen on liz
merriweather is the showrunner yeah yeah
so that would happen and then what what
would would that be up to you to kind of
make it well we would get like the
original version of it
which oftentimes we were like that was
great yeah um
but then we would also then be expected
to sort of open it up and find new
places that's right they did a lot of
vaults right yeah and so like
jake and i specifically when we had
scenes together we were really good at
just like okay well let's give him two
three versions where it's just incent
like one's like a little play on the
script the next one's like all right
let's do it for us the third one's like
let's go to outer space and the fourth
one's like let's let them know that
we're done
would they ever use those takes for the
the last
this is the problem with both you and
jake you're so
good you make that stuff so real still
even like lines like dude that's so
nectar i mean you say you could say
and and a lot of that stuff was it
wasn't overwritten but it was
written it was a lot there was always so
much especially your stuff you had a
mouthful yeah and and but like like so
much of that stuff was liz yeah yeah
yeah like i i wish i could take cred
like the really good the really good
specific stuff yeah that was all liz oh
really yeah man all all of it
matter when when you're i just saw that
clip too when you're mad that jake took
your conditioner he used your
conditioner and you're trying to get it
out it's his first season i think you're
trying to get it out of his hair you go
was that a let's go into outer space
take or was that in the script no that
was i i'm 90 sure that was well jake
max is rubbing jake's hair dude you're
like squeezing his hair and he's like
and he says a funny thing which sounds
like jake where he goes think about what
you're doing right now that's probably
jake he's probably saying
jake
jake is like
jake is probably the best improviser
i've ever worked with me too yeah and
because he does something so he does
something that most improvisers don't do
which is
most guys go after the joke he's
generous and
he finds it funnier to stay back yes and
point out how stupid you're being
[Music]
and it puts you in an uncomfortable
backpedaling situation yeah where you're
you're like you're then spinning your
wheels
yeah something's like oh yeah oh really
he'll encourage you yeah
and then when the tanks are real go that
was one of the dumbest things you've
ever done you should be ashamed of
yourself but i've seen him on the other
end of it too go the other way where he
has to gun for jokes yeah and he is
he is
just as funny or if not like yeah he can
go either way it's almost like he's the
ch he's a chess player who sees the
whole board he's one of those like he's
like a bobby fisher like freakish at
seeing who what he knows the next move
yeah and so when you're the you talk
about how he kind of like sets people up
and encourages you to look like an ass i
think that's only because he knows
what you're gonna do he knows like uh he
just knows but he also knows like by
doing that
he and he intensifies the scene
and he yeah he'll like add these things
like think about what you're doing
and
it creates it creates more stakes in
that scene and then you have a stupid
scene about like you took my conditioner
or whatever the [ __ ] but it's re it
keeps it real no it keeps it real and
like it drops you into a real place and
then you know yeah two idiots yeah being
as dumb as they possibly can we did a
scene where it was just the two of us in
the car and we're going to pick up like
i had an almonds or something and i'm
pointing and i was such a fun we were in
the green screen car thing it was so fun
because i'm just pointing out [ __ ]
that i like mundane stuff i'm like a
really i'm like aggressively boring and
i'll say like oh you know what i i used
to that was the fedex i used to use or
no no wait it looks like no i used
another fedex and jake would go just
like almost under his breath you go oh
really that's that's incredible he
wouldn't say he wasn't like overtly mean
but he was just
he was encouraging but you know
like knowing jake like you see it and
you know that he's like he's if you're a
guy who who
instinctually is going to go after
laughs
he will just keep setting you up yeah
and watch you yeah chase him yeah
like
one of the funniest things i've ever
seen him do because you had a storyline
so you were like you were with him and
he wouldn't encourage you but you were
really see my stuff was always zoey you
had so much stuff as zoe so like so i
kept trying to talk to you guys he would
like he would like he would try to like
reel you in which was not difficult
oh man i would leave her in a scene i
guess i'm the worst i like if the scene
is about oh i'm here to pick up my this
girl that i'm dating zoey and i that's
what the scene is i i'm not in the show
i'm not a radio i just have to go pick
her up and leave and i would
i would she'd get not upset but she'd be
like scenes about us because i would go
like max's name was schmidt i'd go hey
schmidt you'd be in the background we
would have no scripted lines and i go
hey schmidt wha what have you been up to
just
i tried to start with you
at all thing with lamorne it was winston
i'd call her wins i call him winstead
and i kept getting his name wrong never
made it you on the show
truly
yes jake
we're the fun i've i honestly i don't
think i will ever laugh harder at any
performer ever because of that behavior
it was so fun it was the
greatest
because and every time you came in you
were like we were like watch this it's
gonna be good
but it was stuff that i deep down knew
i i didn't have that much experience
with network comedy but i should i still
despite that i knew that it wasn't going
to make it you know but i would a few
little things did i do a few little
things but also that set was so much
about making each other laugh yeah and
keeping like
the insane
tone yeah alive yeah that it was
so great for us
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off off-screen and
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again you were born in
and i love the name of this place dobbs
fairy
mark zuckerberg's from dobbs ferry thank
god yeah yeah with your trajectory you
must
meteoric and meteoric um i do not know
mark i'm honestly just finding this out
now i think i'd heard about it although
i i feel like he's from hastings i'm not
totally sure um oh a research department
uh i'm not i'm not but hastings is right
next door um it's on the hudson right
yeah yeah
it's like a 20 minute training city
train ride to the city would you go into
the city a lot as a kid yeah my dad
worked in the city he was in the record
business and uh and he was like at
cbs records and then sony uh and they
moved over to sony and i used to visit
him at sony a lot and
was he around a lot of musicians was he
was that part he was he was in finance
oh
um
so he was like yes so
he was around a lot of them but like he
saw a totally different version
he had worked
up until i was 18 in new york and then
he got this job with warner brothers and
he moved out to los angeles
and
i remember going to visit him
and
somewhere in the a r department uh they
hired
uh
krs-1
yeah and who was great
um and i remember walking into my dad's
office and my dad was sitting there with
krs-1
and kara's one was like asking my dad
for money because that's what they would
do they would be like we need money to
spend on these videos or on this
so
uh and i walked in and my dad was like
and i guess his name is chris and he's
like chris this is my son max i'm sure
he knows some of your music and i was
like holy [ __ ] it's chaos one and he
comes over me and he gives me like a
full krs one
your knowledge has like keeps me going
and like whatever it was like some
poetry nonsense and i was like holy [ __ ]
south bronx [ __ ] hey man this is
awesome
and then i was just sort of standing
there my dad was like i'll be with you
in a minute and as i like was backing
out i see
krs want to turn back after like putting
on a full voice for me and being like so
marty what i'm really asking for is
that's
you're like that's showbiz i saw the man
behind the curtain that's not how the
wizard talks yeah um
uh you
growing up in in dobbs ferry
you had a
do you remember this you had an snl
themed bar mitzvah
sure
i want to hear about this
feel free to share
um yeah report stuff you have the
enemies like
yeah you have these bar mitzvahs and oh
no you don't have to go that far back so
i get that i get the part of the jewish
tradition
what is that
well it goes back
back in israel
well when a man becomes when a boy you
know at a certain point
no so i was really into snl and it and
your parents come to you and that was
the best and there was like yeah and
there was like
it really was it's like dana carvey
adam sam
like yeah like norm mcdonald it was just
shifting into normal mcdonald's doing
update after dennis miller okay this is
the time i was into it phil hartman it
was the it was the best yeah
and there's like young sandler and spade
and those guys um
yeah yeah and uh and i remember watching
that show and just being like this is
yeah everything these are like truly
superheroes yeah i watched that show as
if those guys were the avengers yeah
yeah
i remember going to a my dad took us to
at the university where he taught uh
mike myers and dana carvey were
performing that was probably 93 92 you
know i was 14 15. and they were like
rock stars i remember being i couldn't
believe they were in and we were way in
the back but then these little specks
were meant so much to me i it's it's
it's insane yeah it truly is well and
they felt so far away as human beings
but yeah you were just
i remember those characters that they
played felt like
especially phil hartman like um caveman
lawyer felt like a different person than
bill clinton and you know like some of
the mike myers stuff oh my god dieter
dieter versus like uh wayne's world or
like simon and i know i think these are
the funniest this is the funniest [ __ ]
i've ever seen yeah yeah so you would
never dane to even imagine that you know
something like that no no no no it
wasn't until like
i had moved out to los angeles and with
your family yeah with at after i
graduated high school and i failed out
of college
what college university of wisconsin
shout out what up what a badgers
.067 gpa
uh well how'd you do that you're smart
um
you did a frida kahlo uh pretty much
yeah i spelled their name wrong they're
like get the [ __ ] out of here they made
me leave this george washington um
totally
um i just was like it was too much i
wasn't right
yeah i i was not i had no patience for
learning things that i knew that i
didn't need
yeah i i did although and now i do isn't
that weird yeah yeah well i'm maturing
very slowly yeah yeah but like truly
yeah no well me too i mean we have kids
at least
i mean i'm a 40 year old single man but
seriously like there were times like
well yeah i'm gonna read a book today
yeah you know i mean for no reason other
than like i want to yeah that's a new
phenomenon yeah so it really is for me
yeah yeah big time yeah i'm like
spacekit are you reading anything now
it's your hiatus so you have time to
well right now and now the report's over
right now it's another report yeah
you're not reading
[Laughter]
how old is your youngest one he's three
what do you teach him now what's he up
to
we were just
he must be hilarious they both must be
hilarious
so far we were in uh we were
volunteering over the school framing all
these these these kids our work we were
talking to some of the other parents and
one of the other moms was like oh yeah
uh
our son who is like five or six had just
done this insane had made this like
beautiful video
and he had written a song about this
african leader and you know played the
guitar with it and it was the whole it
was like a whole thing
and and he was she was telling us about
it and i was like can i see it and we
watched it and we were like holy [ __ ]
he's fine yeah it's like ridic like
ridiculous
so um
i said and my wife with texas was there
and i got a test why don't you show uh
show denise the video of ozzy from the
other night
she goes max i don't i don't really want
to do that i don't know you should it's
comparable
it's a video of ozzy standing over alexa
like the little like the little alexa
one not understanding that you just need
to say it once
[Laughter]
two
begging alexa to make fart sounds
and discovering
that which by the way nazi's defense
that's the first thing i would do
with the fight alexa but alexa alexa
make a fart
[Laughter]
and then and then when it doesn't happen
right away no alexa make a thought
and then
like get like just to the point where
he's frustrated and then all of a sudden
alexa chimes in and goes like this
playing fart noises
one hour and eight minutes
his face lights up and it just starts
going
and he [ __ ] starts laughing in a way
that's like this is yeah this is the
greatest moment of his life is that when
you're like he is my son and
it goes on for like
a while and each one
is funnier than the next him and you're
like oh dear lord so great yeah it
wasn't quite the uh
he's not playing the guitar hero
solo
but in a way just as important maybe you
know maybe he's into percussion
and it showed me like i need to get my
son a drum set we're really quick about
the snl bar mitzvah sure who were you
then everyone had to dress up as a
different character no no no it was like
each table was it you you would identify
the table we had like a the centerpiece
of every table was a headshot of one of
them
one of the current or past cast members
so you might be like at the dan aykroyd
table
um and then
we had like a blues brothers cake
and then um
the party favors were sort of it was
right around the 75th or not the 75th it
was like uh the 15th anniversary 15th
yeah yeah it would have been like 90.
yeah so i think it was 15th
anniversary like a logo at the time with
like the 15
yeah in the in the middle and so it was
like that logo
on the t-shirt and then and it was like
featuring and then it was
it was everybody who showed up at the
bar mitzvah or they were invited on the
back of the tv oh that's great
do you ever meet those guys any of those
those cast members and
are you i i had an experience recently
where i met kevin nealon and i got
really
i kind of regressed a little bit back to
like i was really star struck
i'm trying to think if i've met any of
them
i don't know that i actually have i went
to one of those uh horror conventions
like signing stuff but i was next to rob
i was between rob schneider and paulie
shore and you guys all went out for
dinner afterwards no rob was nice he was
really nice but he was um every once in
a while i would hear
because people were taking pictures with
him and i would hear this um they'd be
like hey they'd want him to do they'd
video him doing his lines from like sure
yeah why not every once in a while i'd
hear this like here
hey hey dude
you can do it
and the worst part was decided
man people make me do schmidt's stuff
all the time all the time what are they
admit what what's like 20 like what's
the 29 youths there's all these really
well what's interesting about new girl
is that it because it's on netflix
mm-hmm you have these like this
never-ending younger generation who just
keeps discovering the show and the way
that they watch it now is they watch
like seven seasons in a weekend yeah oh
my god and they become obsessed with it
and so like our audience has gotten more
intense as time has gone on i gotta tell
you when i did it once it started airing
i got more people
approaching me about that than than
anything i'd ever done
i'll do a couple episodes of this tv
show that's all people talk about i'll
go speak at colleges sometimes mainly
just to teach them how to spell words
and uh universities
[Laughter]
colleges uh yeah so i'll go and like
it's usually a q a
inevitably the questions afterwards i'd
say sixty percent of them was like just
say this dude
yeah you're like yeah because they want
to cut to the chase because right now
everything is just
stories instagram they want to film it
and put it down and like we got him to
say it yeah
how do you feel about that because i i i
struggle with that sometimes i feel
awesome yeah i don't give a [ __ ] really
i couldn't [ __ ] get arrested before a
new girl right and i'm so i mean
honestly so i that job has given me
everything i'll say those lines until
i'm [ __ ] dead
how did you get that job i mean how and
and what was your life how quickly did
your life change
um was it just oh here's pilot season
again and you gotta you you've got a
call back yeah i had some really rough
pilot seasons yeah
up until like
i say that i'm not a great improviser
but i was able to sort of
discover that you could sort of make the
material more your own and once you and
because it used to be that you were
locked in
to the exact words that were on the page
and on a multi-cam you're still
yeah but when single cams came around
you sort of could play through it a
little bit cam is short for camera
yes thank you
but so like i once i started embracing
improv a little bit and then you had
these guys these showrooms these
creators that were coming from a much
different place that weren't coming like
weren't plucked off of friends where it
was every line is this yeah you know you
had some of these like ucb guys who were
like oh my god have fun with that like
yeah it opened me up in a way where i
was like oh i see this is much more fun
and like we could find some like so i
started doing really well yeah
uh audition wise but i couldn't
get anything i was like i was tested for
you know seven shows every pilot season
yeah and didn't get it were they shows
that that ever
ended up becoming things
i mean was there one that you were like
[ __ ]
the one that the one that i really
wanted was the season right before new
girl
which was happy endings oh yeah and i
tested with
adam pally and damon wans oh man and
funny and it was so close to what you
know
new girl ended up being huh which was
which at least in the beginning was
damon and i yeah that's right because
damon did the first episode yeah yeah
and we lost them to happy endings which
got picked up for a second season
um but that was a really close one uh
and i wanted that one those were like
really fun people and david casper who's
great
uh yeah it's a good show and but that
one dragged out and really beat the [ __ ]
out of me yeah so that the next season
and at that point my daughter was like
one it was like one oh boy and i kind of
was like i really don't want to do this
anymore because i didn't want to be the
guy who was like you know having my
daughter in like a car seat and be like
hey uh can i just
guys uh i'm so sorry i couldn't get a
sitter um i'm just gonna put lily here
hopefully she doesn't make any noise and
then like do i was like i'm not doing
that yeah so i really i like very much
considered quitting and called and
reached out about some other you know
normal job opportunities what what kind
of stuff would you do um i called a
buddy of mine who ran hot in cleveland
and i asked them for just like can i be
a writer's assistant on the show or just
any sort of assistant on the show just
like i need a job yeah um and i really
was done i was just like this feels
selfish and not something i want to do
anymore
um
were you depressed was it
was it was is that i was kind of okay
with it yeah i just it was so
frustrating yeah i was like i can't i
don't want to do this and like and i and
i didn't want to express that
frustration in front of my family and i
was like you know it's so funny i've i'm
not in
the fam that boat but i don't have a
family but i've gotten to the point
where of course i'll audition for if
it's score say you know but i i
auditioned for things the last few
auditions i've had i was like
i'm 40 years old and once i turned 40 i
was like well i'm fine i love
auditioning i mean i'm look i'm in a
really fortunate position right now
where if i don't where i i don't need i
don't need to audition for something
because i need to audition yeah yeah
yeah exactly you know i audition for
things because i want to become fun and
you're like let's give it a shot or
you're like i'm never to get this but i
want to go in and read these are cool
people yeah and i enjoy it like i've
i've had done it so much that at this
point it's like not a nerve-wracking
thing for me right
but at the time it was like you just
weren't getting things so oh my gosh
i could not get arrested and was that
that's the thing were you internalizing
that
were you unhappy well you go you you go
between two things which is one part of
you says i'm getting this close on on
yeah and it's bound to happen yeah or
yeah i keep getting so close and it
doesn't happen maybe it's never supposed
to happen
and then i remember there was like this
one pilot it was a multi-cam and i
forget who's in it uh
but i remember reading and being like
this is the one
this is it yeah and i remember like
reading for it and going in giving a
fine reading
and the and the producers being like
thanks so much and i go that can't be
the reaction yeah and then i went home
and i called my agents and i was like
they're gonna need to resee me
and they were like really and i go they
made a big mistake they [ __ ] up
so
i went there like i mean i will i guess
we'll rest i guess we'll see him again
so
i wasn't terrible yeah i went in i went
in two days later i gave the same exact
reason
the same exact read and they were like
yeah sure thanks so much again i was
like
no
and i i remember it vividly because i i
thought
well now i'm done yeah because that was
it because that was the version of what
i had that was it i thought the show was
perfect i was like [ __ ] this done yeah
and the next week i had the new girl
audition
and i was like a little pissed off
and i was like i'm just gonna go in
that's perfect that's a perfect place
yeah and i and i gave i truly like out
of body experience gave the best reading
i've ever given oh wow i wonder if it's
is it interesting that you mentioned
that you had some hostility there was
like a slight bit because there is the
schmidt's like kind of an angry
it didn't didn't show up in the reason
no no no but like i want just to color
it just to color that kind of like
abstinence he's
there's something about him that he was
a fat kid he struggled with that he's
been put upon
there's something that he's always
trying to prove himself
maybe i think it was more i think it was
more just
because
because the real anger came out much
later okay
but but did you read with jake in the
audition in any of the auditions no but
uh well eventually we did yeah the thing
with jake was is that we both got cast
and then we couldn't find the coach roll
which ended up being damon and the pilot
and then lamourne later
damon again
um they knew that they wanted diversity
in that role because they had they just
cast three white people yeah and
they
brought in
every diverse comedic actor so we had to
do a bunch of chemistry reads with all
the guys playing coach yeah so diff so
they're looking for diversity i mean at
one point exhibit you know the rapper
came in
he was very seriously considered for the
role and jake and i had to do multiple
reads with oh man i almost spit mine
with exhibit i
didn't who was like cool
can you imagine the vibe oh my god it
would have changed yeah it's like
amazing wow so then lamorne you read
with the morning was it like oh that's
that guy's [ __ ] great was it did you
know right away um so well damon came in
the first time uh-huh and damon blew
everybody away yeah damon wasn't fully
available right it was second yeah so we
got him to do the pilot the pilot was
great they didn't want to replace him
the pilot so then lamorne came in after
and wow and lamorne is awesome yeah
awesome yeah um
yeah the morning's they've gone through
an interesting uh well la mora has like
a fun trajectory on the show because
he got really [ __ ] in the beginning
because he got the job
sort of based on what they had been
written for
which is a totally different thing than
what lamorne does
and they also because the storyline was
was lamorne's character moving into the
loft uh-huh the second episode couldn't
be
the new lamorne right because it's the
show's the new girl and it's about her
moving in that's true
so they had so they very very plainly
came up to us and we're like look
we're sort of gonna brush over this and
not make it a big deal he's just gonna
come in he's been here you know he's
been here before he's moving back in um
we don't really know like what the
character is yet we're we're just going
to figure it out and that's why i think
my character broke out so
so much in the beginning he relied so
much on you because
lamorin was just sort of there yeah um
and you had this grounded relationship
between
jake and zoey yeah and then all the
punch lines fell to me right right so it
was really a three it was a neighbor
yeah it was a three-hander in the
beginning yeah
and even with jake like jake didn't
really find they didn't start writing
for jake's a genius but they didn't
start writing for his genius until
uh later in that series like this yeah
yeah they sort of like comedically they
sort of you know went in and out with
jake and when when he didn't have to be
like
the hunk uh-huh uh
yeah yeah he's they allowed him to go do
his thing yeah um but then lamorne when
oddly enough when damon came back is
when they found lamourne fully i think
and let him go insane oh really because
then you know
damon came back the second season right
third third or fourth fourth i think oh
wow i'm not sure which one but like
damon then occupied a much different
place and
it allowed lamorin then to just go crazy
and that's what he's best at yeah and i
think so i think at that point you were
sort of like done with schmidt or like
we've seen everything that's done like
yeah
and like it really it was it was very
cool to watch him sort of do his thing
and and and get recognized yeah and now
he's doing i see him everyone's like
he's so funny on instagram i mean jesus
well all you guys are funny on instagram
because you all comment on each other's
stuff
and like kind of tease each other openly
you you like openly mock each other on
instagram totally it's really fun
there's no boundaries i heard somewhere
that you
rediscovered tv or wanting to do tv like
a regular on a tv show because you had
been doing some job out of town and you
were like i miss my kids i want to be
around oh yeah yeah yeah yeah well so
many actors
and i still don't understand this
sort of look at multi-camps like i don't
know that i could ever do that and like
sort of yeah i don't know have this ever
like have this reaction to it yeah this
negative reaction to it then you ask
them what their favorite shows were and
they're like well you know cheers
yeah those are all the [ __ ] shows
that oh multicam is the dream job right
so they're very hard to do because you
have to rely so much on the writing yeah
um so
so i used to always say when we were
doing new girl from the very beginning i
was like if we just kick down one of
these walls and put in a studio audience
we'll make a real tv show that's what
we're doing now is [ __ ]
and we are lined up perfectly to do this
type of show and everybody's like yeah i
mean kind of i mean it never could have
been that but that was my joke and i
always really wanted to be on one yeah
and then
the neighborhood sort of came around
and they were replacing
well yeah they had offered it to me very
early on and at that point i don't know
if you know the the show or like what
you know they after they offered it to
you i think they then offered it to me
sure
yeah
i'm sure but then that guy did it and
well it was look they came to me
the show's about a white family moving
into a black neighborhood it was a white
showrunner white director white producer
and i was like i don't think you need a
fourth wife
pass
i didn't read i didn't read four pages
that's a very white thing to do i was
like uh no yeah let's not do this and
then i heard cedric got involved which i
was really surprised the show runner yes
or the entertainer sorry the energy
but then i heard cedric got involved and
i got and i was really surprised because
i know people work with cedric i had
heard nothing but like truly incredible
things about him he had some development
over at cbs that didn't go through he
really wanted to do a multicam over
there yeah and they said look please
meet with jim reynolds who created the
show why don't you guys sit down you
provide a point of view that he's
incapable of having and if this works it
could be a really beautiful marriage if
it doesn't no big deal but at least we
tried and they sat down and to both of
their credit really worked on this thing
and created
what
you know i think i eventually saw which
was a pilot that made a lot of sense and
and that was so
so strong
on cedric's end the butler family the
the name of his family is the butlers
yeah the butlers he's not playing a
butler no i'm not good that wouldn't
help
was the fear like oh god it's gonna be
like i'm gonna be doing like i'm the
lame white guy and this is no because i
don't think about that like i don't care
about like how i'm perceived or like
yeah what it is no but i mean if the
show
i felt like it felt to me when i saw it
that the show really had
like like legs yeah what do you call
that cedric do you ever make jokes about
him being like cedric the marine
biologist or anything like that you ever
call them different sort of i know i
know that's your instinct
but your max yeah it's something that um
you're max the reserved when it comes to
that well you know look i really want to
every day and as soon as i come and i go
oh look it's cedric that just woke up in
the morning oh man it must be so i mean
everything ah but but you just calm
cedric yeah mainly because that's the
thing
life could be a dream sweetheart
this is why you are one of my favorite
actors
i i was i was very i was lucky enough
because of my wife who works at fox
to see uh
your camera test oh or those original
pictures from that that that show you
did with what with the pilot sober
companion yes oh yeah so i did a yeah i
did a pilot with nick frost where they
don't know what were your requests well
they won the character well first they
wanted me to play the straight man and i
was like god i'd love to play the
character once it was an odd couple
comments yeah yeah i know i said i'd
love to play the the odd one the other
one sure and uh so the cast nick frost
who i love yeah and um and my request
for the character was um i wanted a like
a real bull cut like a like a dorothy
hamill type you know so it was like flat
ironed under and what else um
i think that was it no i remember there
was a make or break on braces oh
yes i wanted braces
i wanted adult braces yeah i wanted
really
they we compromised and they said you
can have the haircut and i as you've
seen the oh they did it in the camera
test the braces i don't know if they did
it oh i know yo yeah they did oh they
did tess sent me a picture
she goes you [ __ ] got it so max's
wife test is the is the casting she's
the head of casting at fox yeah and she
goes you gotta see this [ __ ]
and she sent me that
and
i almost i think i i i can't remember
exactly where i was but i either fell on
the ground or almost got into a car i
said
but all i could think was i was like
where's jake well it's a wonder that
didn't get picked up
[Laughter]
there's
sometimes you commit too much uh it
looks like i don't know
it was ridiculous
for a lead character of a show to look
like that i looked ridiculous and it was
my own hair so i would have had to live
like that i also think it was perfect
and i wouldn't judge a second of it i
loved it it was a no regrets moment i'm
gonna see if i have it what is your most
commonly used as you're on your phone i
i'm less than a what is your most
commonly used emoji would you say either
prayer emoji or the ones that are like
up like this oh like yeah what yeah what
do you call that i'm like yeah you say
it's like praise be oh that's a you so
you use it in a praise b context yes um
if you could be a professional athlete
did you play sports when you were a kid
i mean a little bit but not really but
you were what were you like as you were
you like a theater i like no i was like
kind of okay at everything but i wasn't
great at anything even at theater acting
we didn't really have a program oh
really at
the dobbs ferry high school
um
and so like i wasn't really exposed to
that and i think even more so that's why
you know when i looked at those guys at
snl or just an acting career in general
why it's felt so
insane to me and distant
and it wasn't until i moved out to la
where i was like oh and you're
surrounded people are just auditioning
yeah piece of cake i'm sure i'll get a
show in i don't know a few weeks
cut the [ __ ] 12 years later uh one
snack if you could have one snack from
the trail mix trail mix always really
and jake would laugh at that
always really i'm afraid to look at
serving size on the back of my back to
trail mix because i know that i go so
over
what the actual serving size is that i
just i care not to i'm like how bad can
it be for me it's nuts and who knows
what else is in there
sometimes they have those like little
naughty ones yeah there's like these
like little like things that you're like
i'm not even sure what that is yeah it's
not quite chocolate it's like it dried
something right
i'm so sweet it's in my mouth now so who
cares who cares um and it's good i hope
i get another one of those how many of
those are in there it's like cracker
jacks yeah totally uh the prize what's
your favorite movie of all time or can
you say that yeah i would say uh dog day
oh really yeah that's my favorite movie
ever i just every every
bit about it it's funny it's serious
it's it's that's exciting which one in
the dog day series dog day morning
afternoon or evening uh
the entertainer
dog the entertainer oh jesus um cedric
the bounty hunter
um
uh if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive uh
you've never met who would they be dead
or alive who i've never met um
oh god just going out to dinner seems
like a pain in the ass
[Music]
well you don't have to go out to dinner
they come to you
even still right yeah you can imagine
making small talk with one of these
people it is true what a nightmare you
see like for example i i got to have
dinner not one-on-one but like with
francis for coppola he was at the dinner
this dinner with like maybe eight or
nine people and
well you know i kind of did almost
i said to him because he just wanted to
talk about pasta this is like one of my
favorite directors and sure yeah what do
you what do you so
if you were to imagine having dinner
with coppola you'd think oh great i get
to talking about movies no
he does he wants to talk about pasta and
wine sure i like pasta but i don't know
anything about wine nor do i care i the
people that i find that i really have
respect for and love are the people
whose work that i really admire that
love to talk about it oh yeah um like
rob reiner did new girl about yes that's
right he was you'd be like hey man
i don't want to be i know you're do you
mind talking about spinal tap seven
hours later that's your life awesome
mount um that's so awesome
what are you doing i mean yeah yeah well
i once michael michael winslow i guess
talk to
15 minutes michael winston you know the
guy who makes the sounds i'm sure yeah
i'm your hero yeah and i said michael
i'm so sorry to do this but would you
mind
we was we were doing the same episode of
this tv show together and he was we were
in the makeup trailer i said would you
mind doing some like the some of the
voices and he goes i like the uh maybe
the machine gunner like
i was like amazing what about a distant
dog
you know he's doing all these voices
and like 10 or 15 minutes go by and he's
done quite a few of them and i'm like ah
that's great thanks so much and i
started i said well i started walking
away and he goes well where are you
going i was like oh i'm just going back
to my trailer and he's like i'm all done
i'll
i'll walk with you so i opened the i
opened the makeup trailer door and i
hear
creak
and i look behind me and he's doing the
sound effects i walk down the stabs and
i hear
oh no it's got cell out there hey bro
he as we're walking
is doing sound effects to me walking and
i go so so how long are you here for um
i don't know i was programmed to he's
doing a robot voice and all these voice
and i realized that like
we had i
that was what he did and he you know
when i when i complimented that he felt
like oh this is what i'm going to do now
for the entire time we're having that's
your relationship yeah yeah and that's
cool man the camera guys hated him like
does he would they change the mags and
he would go
you know
he's constantly doing voices um
uh
la or new where would you want to live
if you didn't live in i've done like
i've done almost
20 in new york and almost 20 in l.a
um
i have a fantasy about nashville even
though i've never been there i don't
know
but i've i've like yeah again nightly
would be like oh man just yeah you know
me and a jumbo gibson j50 yeah just
sitting out there [ __ ] it dude yeah
ozzy and lily dancing and listening to
some country music sure why not i had
that about austin i was like i'd be nice
yeah settle in austin totally i'll move
my family that i don't have to austin if
you could have uh either super x-ray
vision or super hearing which would you
choose hearing
i can't i'm like i feel like i feel like
i'm going deaf oh
if there's like two if there's like two
noises happening at the same time like
the air conditioner is on and my
daughter's in the back seat and i'm
trying to have a conversation with her i
constantly i'm like what oh
no lil you gotta speak up you can't and
then i'm doing frida who yeah and i'll
like yeah and i'm like and it seems like
i'm yelling at her and i realize and i'm
like max what are you doing if you could
be one age for the rest of your life
what what would you pick visit
physically oh physically yeah for me
physically
uh
when i was
probably 31 i was in good shape yeah
first season a new girl yeah oof um wow
you're sweating
through the memory i'll never get back
there yeah i think i i i and there's a
sick part of me thanks ryan murphy in
the back of my head i go i think to
myself
i could get back there if i needed to
and i know that's not true well
for the right director
yeah that's right well that night with
trump yeah i would i i told you told him
that max would get back into that
yeah but that dinner with cople at one
point i said um
i i asked him if i was trying to ask him
about movies and stuff and and i'm
sitting across from it was for this
movie cheaper's creepers and it was a
german company that like financed the
whole movie he was with his family and i
felt so bad that they weren't able to
direct that movie he produced it okay
and um he's at the head of the table
holding court and i felt so bad for this
this german family and at one point out
of nowhere i just said um
i i said oh you know my dad was just in
germany he was just there and uh
and the guy goes
and i said he he gave a paper he gave
he's a teacher he gave it like i'm
trying blanking on the name and there's
just this awkward like i said i'll
remember it he goes uh okay
and they kind of went back to speaking
german and german amongst each other and
at one point as coppola is like in the
middle of a story i go oh i remember
where he was uh buchenwald buchenwald
does the name buconvault mean anything
to you and everyone stopped coppola
stopped it was silent there was like
silverware like hitting plates and
i go what yeah boukenvault that was it
do you know that is that a school or
something and the guy german guy beat
red he goes he has this uh
concentration camp
they go oh and i said this these words i
said
i think he brought something back
like is there a maybe a museum or like a
gift shop i said gift shop
gift shop and cut it out but um
going to cut most of this out uh
but yeah so i embarrassed myself i
thought i was going to get fired for
sure for sure uh
uh
what do you prefer um here's what i'd
like for you to do it yeah
next time you see francis for coppola
which should be soon bring up that story
again and go
it was it was a bit
i was doing a bit
and i and i never had the opportunity to
tell you uh but rob reiner was cool
about it he was cool yeah totally those
kind of guys i really like like uh i
could spend hours
yeah totally like uh
tom morello is a dad at our school oh
wow and he loves talking about guitar
you're talking about guitars for days
and you're like you're the coolest yeah
um
another guy who who's really nice like
that and generous bill hader yes he's so
good on snl and i remember like bumped
into him early on a new girl and i was
really excited to meet him yeah and i
was like man you did some sketch
literally i was like you did some sketch
like three weeks ago that was i i'm
sorry to be like such a nerd about this
but it was it was it honestly it made me
laugh so hard and he was like oh my god
when we did this and this is how we came
up with it and this and like started
really giving back
thank you this is really nice this is a
nice thing i'm not like i'm not trying
to go to dinner with you next week i
don't want like hey you should meet like
we are our fan our kids should meet i
was just like i really was into that
thing
it was totally it made me laugh and made
me think about how you did it how you
came up with it and you're answering all
those questions and this is so nice yeah
yeah uh okay really quick beetles or
stones stones really although it's tough
wow
do you have to give up the other one uh
yeah i've lived with the stones dogs are
cats oh dogs for sure you you're did you
go camping are you a camper oh my god
just i just got back from camping
no i do not
well we'll set this at the table for me
what is camping with you look like well
first of all like this was this was
hardly camping these are like little
lodges in the woods and mountains
yeah to a degree yeah um not i don't
think full out but pretty much
and um what what made you decide to do
that the whole there was a bunch of
people from the school going uh-oh
and uh i just like
it's not for me i don't feel comfortable
i i i i
you grew up in a i mean you didn't you
didn't grow up i just i really like to
shower uh-huh yeah
and then i feel
[ __ ] gross after a few hours yeah
there's dirt in places that like i want
to get that i want to get it out of
there i can't if i can't take a proper
shower it's like why is there dirt like
behind my ear i didn't do anything why
it's just it's in the air yeah did you
when it's in your nose yeah everywhere
and then you're like why is my nose
bleeding yeah yeah finally really quick
how has your life changed this is bigger
but but with kids do you look at time
differently now do you look at like how
am i going to spend my time do you look
at that differently since you've had
kids well justin i mean i know that's a
deeper question but like
i i struggle a lot with like what to do
with now that time is becoming more
precious and and
you know getting older getting closer
they're gonna die yeah yeah sure well
we're gonna die anyway we are regardless
of kids do you think about that often is
that the kids oh really every morning
really no no no no
thinking about it right now well i hope
so
uh that's you know it's not the happiest
note to end on but but do you have a i
did i did a movie with uh or a show with
barry sonnenfeld
and there was young kids on it and i was
trying to explain to them what a midlife
crisis was
and i looked over bear i go barry you i
mean you must have some insight on this
i go have you ever had him
during the midlife crisis and he goes no
and i go
i know
really and he goes how am i going to
have a midlife crisis i've been in
crisis my whole life get on your mark
uh
thanks for do man thanks for doing that
i mean look it was awesome to see you
it was awesome to see you i do you have
like a sign off yeah just kind of like
yeah peter's out awkwardly that's
cool that's cool
[Music]
that happened
oh
boy it's getting hard to
i can't believe we maintain that i know
but now it's also like oh it's kind of
fun it's part of the show it's like a
regular thing uh
i don't i really flip flop there you
sure did
so that happened yeah it did happen and
um
so glad it happened and it's the kind of
thing i want to have happen more i would
say of all the episodes we've had thus
far and we've had a pretty good number
maybe 15.
um
that was the best fly on the wall
episode hmm you know what i mean just in
terms of like an annoying fly like you
want to smack like a tt fly
uh no it
not annoying fly it's it was
it didn't get that deep
uh like some of the other interviews
have gotten yeah but it was really fun
because it was just like listening to
two funny people catch up and hang out
you know it was really fun to listen to
i thought that's great this hasn't aired
yet i hesitate to talk about it but it
reminded me a lot of the interview we
did with pope francis yeah that was
equally giggly yeah yeah just two pals
uh shooting the [ __ ]
you know it's hard for me to like uh
that fly on the wall um idiom i think
it's an idiom a fly in the wall to be a
fly on the wall but that's saying
whatever it is uh it's hard for me to
hear in a positive way because you hate
flies i hate flies so much but christian
i've been up at uh i have a place in
massachusetts on a lake and in the woods
it's really pretty but it was um
for whatever reason this year is just
like infested with these you know those
flies that i don't know what they are i
think they're horse flies that follow
you around
it's very annoying but i still prefer i
would take 10 flies to one mosquito or
you're insane i don't mind flies those
flies that we've been dealing with
they're annoying but they don't i don't
just swat them away but mosquitoes
that's the thing with these flies you
can't just swat them away gotta swat
them hard
all right chris jericho
uh no they just keep coming what if we
only reference people who've been on the
show
uh they keep coming back
no they are annoying awful
i thought it was interesting that he was
so obsessed with snl as a kid but
he didn't have the confidence that some
of our other guests have had i mean you
say chris jericho he's like the opposite
where he didn't think even remotely that
he had remote chance to make that show
or to do anything like those people do
uh he talks he says as
he refers to himself as a kid he said uh
you know when i was a kid i was kind of
okay at everything but great at nothing
and i think a lot of people can relate
to that i i certainly could i was kind
of good at a lot of things degraded
nothing but yeah it's interesting to
hear someone who i consider
so good at what he does and funny and i
know to hear him refer to himself as
being oh it's okay well a lot of his
comedic point of view comes from a
self-deprecating place i think and on
that show this [ __ ] he did was so um it
was almost like unhinged i mean they
would just let him go it was sort of
fearless like you say i think you
described them as um
you're like you really go for it yeah
and he really does go for it but i
wonder if
part of the reason he's able to really
go for it is because he struggled for so
long he talks about how he didn't get he
couldn't get arrested he couldn't get
you know pilot season after pilot season
he couldn't get work and then when he
finally got that job it's like i wonder
if he felt
more incentivized to like really go for
it you know i wonder what the psychology
is because he
he doesn't strike me as somebody who
was not able to get a job and i by that
i i mean
an acting job an acting job that
hollywood wouldn't know wouldn't
recognize a talent like that you know
right but maybe it just took a script
like liz's and like uh maybe
you know because those weren't the
typical tv roles he's he doesn't look
like the wacky neighbor certainly he's
handsome and
so
maybe it was that like you see john
ritter i would never think oh that guy
is like one of the most gifted physical
comedians right he's just handsome i but
he was given an opportunity and he fully
[ __ ] embraced it well along those
lines you i thought you made a very
astute observation when you said
when he was talking about his new girl
audition and how
he
kind of went into that he was like you
know two days away from quitting the
business and so he went into that
audition
with kind of a chip on his shoulder and
he he denies that this had anything to
do with it but that character has a kind
of totally anger too totally and yeah
that's what's huge i mean i who am i to
say that he would know better than i
would i think but uh i it sounds like
that observation has some truth to it
what you said you know that he went into
that audition with a little chip on his
shoulder some anger and it it certainly
didn't hurt
no uh and i think that's why he was able
to commit to that character in a way
that if you want to watch like the level
of commitment i'm talking about the best
thing to do is to wat and he references
those takes that he and jake did that
were just like off the rails let's just
see what happens if you want to see
those watch the gag reel i think there's
a there's one for every season of new
girl but
on youtube you can watch the gallery of
those shows and and i would say 80 of it
is uh is is max being
so [ __ ] funny and insane and and uh
there's one scene in particular i'm
thinking about he makes dermot maroony
laugh and dermot moroney
i always confuse with dylan mcdermott
but he keeps making him laugh and max
has this kind of like
almost like aggressive like laser focus
in the scene he's just like committing
to it he's
it's so fun to watch to watch those gag
reels they're [ __ ] great how badly do
you want to watch
exhibits audition
for winston oh
man that would be amazing exhibit was
very personable and charming on that
show remember that show he hosted um
pimp my ride am i right that's right
i'll be my ride
[Laughter]
that's my ride that's the weight is
that's fine um at one point i know that
you
uh
had an offer to do
his part he's playing the neighborhood
and you were conflicted about
whether or not you should tell him
because i know there's something kind of
it's a little so not insulting because
you also don't know the when you got the
offer right well you could have gotten
it well here's the thing i i i faced
this with i didn't get the jesse
eisenberg interview i remember like when
zombieland came up i was very close to
that part and i even read with woody
harrelson and it was this whole thing
and i got whatever it was close and i
and i
it's different because he got the part
and so i didn't want to bring it up for
i didn't want to make him feel weird but
with with max i
i don't think i would have brought it up
in fact i know i wouldn't have brought
it up had he not said
oh they offered it to me that i turned
it down oh okay my guess and i'm i'm
sure this happened is that i got offered
it after he already turned it down
uh-huh you know so i would never have
said
you know they wanted me yeah
i wouldn't have said that yeah so ben
kingsley if you're listening if you got
if i got a part first and then you
picked it up after i turned it down i
won't bring it up uh
you couldn't let go of yeah sir yes uh
you couldn't let go of the cetera et
cetera
different cedric jobs cedric the
showrunner
the destitute
you couldn't like call back jokes
i i it's to me it's i don't think i'd be
able to
stop making cedric the something i mean
the audacity it takes oh man to name
yourself imagine if you called yourself
justin the entertainer it's like saying
justin the great
it's almost greater than that it's
almost yeah
more arrogant we should save this for
the cedric episode
cedric the podcast uh you talk about the
uh your luke and sober companion that
pilot you did on fox the bulk the
dorothy hamill look yeah
that was so i mean you've done some
short-sighted things in your time
but if that show had become successful
that would have been the single most
short-sighted thing you would have had
to live with that haircut yeah for
potentially seven eight years and even
when they didn't because what they would
do to get the dorothy hamill quality
they would uh flat iron it and they
would kind of like do curl it underneath
so it had this kind of like lift to it
this like wait it had bounce that's the
word
it was
ridiculous i got to put a picture i
think i did put a picture on instagram
it's like one of the first things i
put on instagram if you follow me but
even without it being like flat iron and
all that like when i would walk around
with i had to wear a hat because it was
a ridiculous haircut to have into a
sombrero to cover the entire thing i had
to wear a
a beekeeper outfit thank god that show
didn't get picked up well but it would
have been really [ __ ] fun god that
was a fun such a funny script and and
you know the woman who did that um who
created that show jenny irman she
had another show that she was like
i don't think the other thing's going to
get picked out but i definitely think
this thing's gonna pick up and the other
thing she had was uh jane the virgin oh
my god
if you all know what happened if only
you had a less dumb haircut maybe uh i
was like jimmy you would have been on
jane the virgin yeah yeah you were like
john the virgin
[Laughter]
uh finally i thought it was really funny
that
yeah
he doesn't want super hearing but he
just wants improved hearing because he
thinks he might be going deaf yeah that
to me is such a modest goal well it's
funny that our two like when i think of
jewish comedy like guys who whose roots
aren't i know max talks about how what a
big influence snl was but i'm sure
there are jewish roots even jewish
sensibilities to his comedy in a great
way in a way that i i really have
discussed with jesse really identify
with and um
uh i wonder
what that is that those two guests have
had that in common that their super
super strength was uh very modest yeah
purchasing power yeah jesse had
purchasing
yeah i want to get a good deal on socks
i want to bike just a little bit faster
yeah yeah and max yeah but but i i
really love that point of view and and
uh
you know i forgot i hadn't seen max in
so long and we text a lot but when you
text with somebody or follow someone on
instagram it's like yeah that's really
sad to say i
you forget how great they are and what
attracted to you them enough to them in
the first place um well it was i'm glad
that i was a fly that was it was a fun
fly to be oh good not like the ones that
i've been dealing with no uh do you want
to read a yeah email yeah do you have
one no oh i have some here okay yes um
this is from carolyn
i don't know if it's caroline or carolyn
i never get that right we have a cousin
named uh carolyn rose and uh i always
have to i do a stutter step before i say
her name because i for some reason
always get tripped up on that caroline
caroline it's carolyn i know our cousins
carolyn if you're listening i hope you
are listening this i think is carolyn
b um she writes a very nice letter dear
long brothers for 30 years i was an
extremely faithful mormon i had all the
answers to life's questions yet i was
depressed and anxious every single day i
felt like i was never good enough the
pursuit of perfection according to
mormon standards was exhausting and
confusing i was conditioned not to
question anything
while being told that mormons were the
only ones with true happiness i was
doing everything right so why wasn't i
happy in my process of leaving the
church i noticed how much others were
living for the next life that life
started to sound like a social club to
me not a heaven i would enjoy as a queer
feminist who didn't like coercive
polygamy
and she goes on to talk about that and
um
and she says i don't know what happens
after this life but that means i live in
the now the good things i do are genuine
and come from the heart not from some
idea of mansions and rewards in heaven i
appreciate and enjoy my family and
friends
uh for who they are and love to hear
their stories they are no longer people
to mourn convert or keep on the path of
righteousness the path that is easiest
for white cis straight able people abled
people to keep they are flesh and blood
not numbers i am flesh and blood too my
happiness is important my individuality
is a gift life is a thing to explore
deconstruct and treat with curiosity
being open-minded allows us to have a
more balanced and genuine inner
environment which then gives us the
opportunity to reduce our harm to the
external environment the impact we make
in the here and now matters everyone
deserves agency dignity and a chance to
live their true and complete life um
carolyn that was really carolyn b is a
fantastic writer she really is and i and
i know i read that kind of quickly and
and without the but it's even reading it
quickly it reads really beautifully and
forgetting the content of it which is
really quick and for anyone
who's listening who happens to be a
mormon that's okay too if that's what
makes you happy exactly and if it's not
causing any harm to anybody and if that
is where you drive happiness uh it just
so happened that carolyn was not
deriving happiness from that lifestyle
and and i'm so glad she is now she is a
beautiful writer and i'm glad she's
she's listening it reminded me actually
of like in terms of living in the here
and now uh christian i recently met
somebody whose friend had a funeral
while he was still alive and i never
heard of that i never heard of doing
anybody doing something like that but it
makes total sense to me that he had all
of his friends over and they celebrated
him they had a big party and
and they they
kind of eulogized him uh and he was able
to experience it and
maybe because caroline touches on this
in her letter we don't know what's out
there afterwards and if there is
something i really hope to god there is
but
you know if there's not we know that
this is here we know that we're here
with our friends and and experiencing
life with with our loved ones so i don't
know i thought that was really cool i'd
like to be a fly on the wall in my own
funeral yeah right it'd be fun what if
you didn't have to be a fly you were
just your human self or that i might be
get a little uncomfortable actually with
people eulogizing
yeah i i'll be a fly yeah yeah hopefully
you won't be reincarnated as a fly ugh
you'll be a better than a mosquito uh i
don't think so anyway
uh not this again you go debate
everybody
anyway if you want to send an email yes
um please do and maybe we'll read it
uh it's life is short at wondery.com
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
thank you as always for listening to
life is short if you like the show tell
your friends to subscribe we're
available on apple podcast spotify
google podcasts and every major
listening app as well as wondering.com
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by christian long and
megan monaco our senior producer is
michelle lanz mish
engineers marcelino viapando executive
produced by marsha louis and ernan
lopez for wondering
and in what movie
uh i i just saw some movie i just don't
recognize what i saw like you fat fat
really you know i was skinny i'm skinny
now and in the movie i was fat yeah yeah
maybe uh maybe about five years ago five
years ago when i was fat yeah yeah
maybe uh you you're giving uh
keep fit now oh maybe yeah i've been
i've been
taking care of myself yeah yeah cause
i'm skinnier now yes yeah look good you
know
look you know not fat like i used to be
yeah yeah well only that the face face
was fat yeah now skin now
i think you die you like oh okay maybe
yeah yeah you die you look good
thanks thank you that's nice of you i
wonder what the movie was where i was
fat
ah
the the movie i
i just don't just look in the uh picture
oh picture yeah fat face picture yeah
yeah yeah
but people are real people um
look good better yeah yeah right i don't
know it depends
i guess maybe i've lost a little weight
i didn't realize that yeah you roast me
oh okay well that's good
[Laughter]
so how how
uh how
we how many pounds you know
how many pounds yeah i'm pretty fine
ladies that's it yeah this is it yeah we
almost made it
how many pounds i don't know how many
pounds i lost yeah i think you lost
pound wow
i didn't think about that i get i don't
know now i'm trying to remember how much
i weighed
when i was fat
and now that i'm skinny
i don't know
maybe the pizza look you have fatter
yeah
yeah
fat picture i i i told you tonight yeah
tonight okay tell me tonight you say
you'll tell me tonight okay okay yeah
i'm curious
you